bonjour bonjour vous êtes jeune et spa
non c'est la première fois que j'ai vu
alors je vous ai rencontrés ailleurs non
je ne sors jamais en tout cas dans les
mêmes centres à que vous je suis sûr
vous me rappelle quelque chose
la couleur de votre moto moto alors la
couleur des banquettes de métro
quelle drôle d'idée j'ai une voiture
vous savez non j'y suis ils ont
exactement la couleur des forêts de
corrèze à midi après un orage de tonnes
c'est joli la corrèze c'est encore plus
beau que je croyais un et vous changer
leur couleur mais famille liens aussi
c'est celle des coussins de cette
voiture
cette obsession non c'est celle de ma
première guitare celle sur laquelle je
compose encore toute la musique elle est
d'un joli bois brun mais moins chaudes
leveaux vous savez ce que vous devriez
faire
oui vous épousez ce n'est pas ça oh non
enfin si mais je voulais simplement que
vous méritiez à donchery parlera tout le
vit pendant ce temps ça tout le temps
non il faudra quand même que je chante
quelquefois je pourrai vous accompagner
si vous êtes ma femme bien sûr quand on
attendait le 13 juillet oh non pourquoi
elle voulait pas lire ce journal
aussi bien alors tout sera formidable on
partira tout de suite après la cérémonie
commence à remercier les gens pour les
cadors mais quel cadeau mais quelle
horreur on aura pas de cadeau
autant dire à personne qu'on se marie en
irak où j'ai une série télévisée aux
enfers l'étranger on en profitera un
gand liège charleroi
rome venise naples milan et après après
on ira prendre de vraies vacances c'est
votre grand mère
comment les avez vous deviné c'est une
femme formidable douce bonne indulgente
une vraie grand-mère de comptes de feu
et où habite elle en corrèze justement
dans une vieille baraque merveilleuse
avec des grandes cheminées des feux de
bois était en pétrole et brew et oui il
ya des brutes plein de fleurs dans le
jardin mais je vis dans un rêve
l'importance du moment que c'est le même
que le mien qu'avez-vous j'y suis je me
souviens matin je sais où je vous ai
déjà vu noir oui vous je vous me donnez
plus d'un rendez-vous mais mes os à
aucun de mes rêves et j'y venais souvent
[Musique]